[MUSIC]
JODI SCHOTTENFELD-ROAMES: MOL 350 is really
designed to prepare students as juniors
to be able to walk into
their labs as seniors,
perform their senior thesis,
already have the ability
to read primary literature.
So they work with
drosophila and they're
focusing on the tracheal
system of flies.
It's incredibly analogous to
the vertebrate vascular system.
They're doing what's called
amino fluorescence, where
they're tagging
certain proteins,
and then they're using
a microscope called
a confocal microscope so that
they can visualize the stains
that they're looking at.
EVELYN WU: Being exposed to these
experimental techniques
early on helps us understand not
just the steps that we're doing
but really understand why
we are doing these steps.
ANNIE CHOI: By looking at the
confocal microscope,
we actually know how
the results would
look like in an
actual microscope
rather than being given the
example image in a textbook.
EVELYN WU: To be able to
generate that image
ourselves is really,
really exciting.